PAUL KINLAN: Hello everyone.
My name is Paul Kinlan.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Hello.
PAUL KINLAN: Hello.
You are?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Karsten Schmidt.
PAUL KINLAN: Hi.
We're here today to talk
about DevArt and the work
that you're doing with
that DevArt project,
what the DevArt project is, kind
of how you can get involved,
and how you can start to kind
of explore some of the things
that you might want to
do inside that project.
So I think it's probably best
to start with an introduction
to DevArt and what DevArt is.
So DevArt is a project
by Google in combination
with the Barbican,
where we've commissioned
a number of developers to create
new digital art, essentially,
which will appear
inside the Barbican
in a digital
revolutions exhibition.
The really cool thing
is that there's actually
an extra slot open for a
developer through the DevArt
project to be commissioned,
or to be commissioned
alongside the three
artists that we've got.
And one of those
artists is Karsten.
One of the things
I will say, though,
is that what we're trying to
do with the DevArt project
is take developers
and let them explore
their creative abilities.
Sometimes, me especially
as a developer,
I don't normally think
I'm that creative.
But given some inspiration,
I can go and do
some really cool things
inside the art space
with code and
computer technology.
And that's what we're trying
to inside the DevArt project.
So with that, I will
just hand over to Karsten
and let you introduce
yourself to our audience
and let people know what
they might know you for.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Who I am.
OK, I'm Karsten.
From East Germany,
but been living
in London for 15 years
now, or 16 years.
And I started when I was 13
years old writing for six years
roughly just assembly and
hex code on the 8-bit Atari.
And I joined the
local demo scene,
which then became less local
and became more Europe wide.
And then, when I was 18, I
wrote a port of "Lemmings"
for the Atari, and then I
had enough of computers.
PAUL KINLAN: When
you say Atari, do
you mean Atari ST or the Atari--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
The 8-bit Atari.
PAUL KINLAN: The 2600?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: No,
the 800XL or 130XE.
That whole group or family.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh wow, OK.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: The
last 8-bit Atari, really.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh wow.
My dad used to fix
Ataris like crazy.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, anyway.
That's a side story.
Doesn't really matter that much.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yeah, let's
not start with the C64 on Atari.
And then I had
enough of computers.
Made music for four years.
Had my own studio.
And from that, I really--
from my demo scene days,
because I've kind of been
thrown in the deep end totally,
and I had no idea of
programming before or actually
what a computer is.
So we had in our heads
no distinction of this
is programming, this is
making music, or chip tunes,
or making your own types or
icons for tools you needed,
or making your own big font
for scrolling text and all
that stuff.
So for us it was really
everything related.
And almost everything was
achieved through programming,
because in the old days,
there were no tools, really.
If you wanted to do
interesting things,
you had to write your own stuff.
And I think that mentality,
in hindsight now,
was really the best
school I ever got.
And it was especially
that first year,
we had eight months time to do
a computer game from scratch.
None of us knew anything.
And it was insane pressure.
We had only one hour
computer time a week.
And everything else
happened on paper.
And that's why I
still have now most
of my work, which is not related
to actually typing in code,
it's still notebook
based really.
And I can see how this
will change really.
Like with the tablets and--
PAUL KINLAN: So I'm trying to
compare your notes to the notes
that I've made.
So everyone can't see
this on the screen, but--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PAUL KINLAN: It's
a very in depth
kind of notepad with a lot
of ideas about what he's
trying to do inside this
DevArt project at least.
I don't know whether we're
going to get the chance
to go through all
that sub stuff today.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Probably not.
I mean, you can go to
the DevArt website.
I will document my
project in more detail
than I've done so far,
because it's still early days.
There's a lot of moving ground.
PAUL KINLAN:
Actually, that's one
of the really interesting
things about the DevArt project,
is that the site itself is
powered by GitHub, essentially.
Well, the server
is on App Engine
and a whole lot of other stuff.
But the actual back end itself
where you would normally
have this weird CMS
where you're actually
trying to manage projects
is actually done and powered
by GitHub.
So Karsten's code and all the
blog entries that you're making
are all in this one
repository inside GitHub.
So you--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: And
mostly there are 3D files.
And I made some mockups
for the exhibit.
So these are all Blender
files, for instance.
So you can find them.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
As I recall, you can
basically take the code,
follow exactly what
Karsten's doing,
kind of Commit by Commit by
Commit, which is really cool.
And the other two artists
as well are Zach--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Lieberman.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
Zach Lieberman.
And-- I keep always getting the
name wrong-- Varvara and Mar.
They're also all got their
projects on GitHub as well.
And you can follow
along as you go along.
And there's the code side of it.
And then there's also the--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: The assets.
PAUL KINLAN: The assets,
yeah, and the posts.
So it is like many
blog posts, all
powered by the
Markdown engine that's
been built into it as well.
So you can follow
everything along.
It's really nice.
And you can just go
to the DevArt site
if you don't want
to go to GitHub
and just view all the
content from there.
So probably a lot of people
who are watching this
know you from the Processing
scene as well and a couple
of other things.
Do you want to kind of talk
about where you went with that?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yeah, so the
reason I actually stumbled
or came across Processing
really more or less by accident.
Because I've been
doing web development
from like '95 to 2005 really.
And I've been spending
a lot of my time
with Director and with Flash.
And I really realized that
it's quite scary an endeavor
to focus your entire
livelihood on a single tool.
And so I started
looking for options
and going back more to my roots.
And not use a premade
tool but actually start
working on my own
tools yet again.
And I came across Processing
just by looking around
for what is there Java
based at the moment.
And it was really still young.
It was 2003, spring 2003.
And I found it
super interesting,
and I just shoot an
email to Casey and Ben
in how I can help.
And I did then end up
contributing a few little bits
to the graphics engine.
But mainly started really using
Processing for my own work
and realized that this is really
transforming everything I knew
and actually everything
I wanted to do,
but didn't really have the
tools to do that beforehand.
And so it became, really, a
stepping stone in my career.
But then I also
realized that there
are a lot of things
in Processing
which are really more or less
focused on just the display
side.
And really aiming for this
creative computing field as it
was emerging back then.
And I was more focused on
actually doing something which
allows you to solve
actual design problems.
So where you have, for
instance, not where it's
a tool which is not just
making it easy to draw objects
on screen, but actually
work with those objects
as abstract entities
to do stuff with them.
So for instance, instead
of just drawing in
libs on screen, which you can do
in Canvas with one line of code
or in Processing with
one line of code,
the computer system
has no idea that this
is a circle you
are just drawing.
So what I started
then focusing on
is to actually
provide a set of tools
which allows you to work with
geometry initially as entities
which you can analyze
and combine and transform
from one into another.
And I think I
realized how important
that is to actually solve
real world projects, you know.
And how you can
actually combine this
with all the other interesting
things going on at the time
and also now.
Like, say, agent-based systems,
particle systems, physics.
And then it just exploded
from there, really,
in terms of scope.
And in 2007, then I took
that seriously, really,
and started setting up my own
studio, or really my own design
practice.
It wasn't ever a studio, really.
And there I really tried to
focus for the first two years
to recheck any form of
project which would not
allowed that new open
source project to grow.
So basically, I
turned down every work
which would create some
form of repetition.
And that actually allowed
me to work with people
I never could work before.
With like lighting designers,
architects, and that kind
of other part of
the design world.
And that, I still think, is
the most interesting part
of my job today.
I'm always trying to meander
between the commercial design
world and the more artistic,
free form expression, which
for me is mainly just research
for future and more pragmatic
projects.
PAUL KINLAN: So I
suppose like-- this
is going to sound stupid--
is that the fun part for you?
Or is it-- is this like--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
I don't really-- I
think it's a hard question.
I think what is good when
you have a client project--
and even this is essentially
a client project, you know.
It's only in the art world we
called those people patrons
versus clients.
So I think the dynamics are not
that actually very different.
But I think what always helps
is if you have a deadline.
It just stops
procrastination and it
keeps you focused on
achieving results.
But I think the kind
of process is not
very different to how I would
do a commercial project.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, that's cool.
So what I wanted to start us
talking about now, recently
at least anyway, is more on
the everything is inside the,
I want to say, digital
space, inside the computer.
How do you see
this kind of work?
We're going to show this
work in a little bit as well.
How do you see the
interaction between, say,
software and physical objects
and those type of experiences?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Well A, everyone
knows it and it's
happening all around us.
But this convergence of--
and I really hate the word
but there's no better
English word for it.
PAUL KINLAN: It's
better than synergy.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yes, OK.
Yes, point taken.
But I think everyone talks
about that everything
becomes more and
more digital and we
have more of our computing
elements and all sorts
of objects which we didn't
have even five years ago.
And I think what we
don't really realize yet,
and a lot of people actually who
do more like software research
they actually are becoming
more and more aware of it
that hardware progress
is not slowing down,
but software progress actually
is almost the more slower
and software is
not there anymore.
PAUL KINLAN: Why's that?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Because
a lot of our algorithms
were designed in the '60s.
A lot of the key
algorithms-- and they
don't actually transpose
that easily to a multi-core
or fully distributed system.
So I think we need a lot more
different ways of programming
and actually thinking
about what code can do
and how it actually does it.
And that really means
we need to think more
about the languages we
use in the first place.
And that's something which
became, in the last three years
for me, really
the main interest.
To figure out A, because
software technology has
progressed so far now that we
can design so-called domain
specific languages
for, say, this project,
I will design my own
little language simply
because it makes a
lot of things easier.
But the same thing can be
applied to more bigger aspects
as well.
And if you look at the history
of programming languages,
you can really see
how much crossbreeding
there is going on all the
time between those languages.
And especially recently, we have
this kind of Cambrian explosion
of languages where there's
so many coming out.
Like Mozilla released
Rust now and this
is what they're
heavily investing in.
C++ has a new version even
though there is not that much
impact happened, not much change
compared to previous ones.
PAUL KINLAN: So do
you see-- I don't
know whether this is the
right question or not.
These languages like Rust,
C++, even Java Enclosure--
which we're going to
talk about in a minute--
they're all very
low level, right?
Like they're designed
for programmers, right?
When we talk about
DSLs, do we see that
or do you see that going towards
more of the consumer space
so people can build their own?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Yes, but there, I
mean it's again what do
you consider programming?
That's also one of
two things I want
to explore in the
DevArt proposal is
that what I'm
basically proposing
is a kind of visual
form of programming
which is super limited.
It only has less
than five operators,
or less than five words.
And that kind of limitation,
history has shown us
many times, has intense scope
for creative exploration.
Because there's not
much to understand
in terms of learning
vocabulary, and people
who are interested to
achieve a certain idea,
they will push those available
options to their limits.
And I think if we think
about more recent projects
like Node-RED, IBM's
thing and-- there's
another similar note-based
[INAUDIBLE] kind
of visual programming
thing which is coming out.
I mean that has a
long history which
is running pretty
much in parallel
to the text based
form of programming.
But I think those kind of high
level approaches to arranging
moving bits of logic into
a consumer friendly way
is happening more and more.
There's also an
if-then, then that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yes.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: And these are
all-- you can't call them DSLs,
but technically they are.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: They have
been so repurposed and so
much designed and consumerized
that you can't call them
a programming language as
such, but there's definitely
an element of a
language in there.
PAUL KINLAN: So you
mentioned about the idea
of this really
constrained language which
will help you
build your project.
Well, help people who
interact with your project
build things with it.
Do you want to
explain a little bit
about what your
project is for DevArt?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yes.
So the idea of DevArt or
of my project for DevArt
is that there will
be a 3D printer
in the exhibit in the museum.
And that printer will
print one object per day.
And visitors in the
museum will basically
take over the role
of the curator
and choose what objects will
be printed for the next day.
So there's a running vote.
And if an object
has been printed,
it can't be printed
again, simply
to keep the pool
open for newcomers.
And the other main
part, and it's really
the main part of the project,
is a web based design tool slash
exploration tool, which
is open to anyone, really.
So I'm hoping that will be able
to run on a tablet as well.
That's pending hardware.
PAUL KINLAN: Using [INAUDIBLE]?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yes of course.
PAUL KINLAN: You would
probably be good.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Of course, yeah.
I mean, they--
PAUL KINLAN: It could
work on an Android tablet,
it might not work on an iPhone.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yeah, no.
The thing is too I
think with webtrees
as to the difference
between rendering
and actually
geometry generation.
So I think the
geometry generation,
you can do obviously
in open share,
you can use geometry shaders.
But there's still
a big difference
what has to run on
the CPU versus GPU.
But we have App Engine, we
have Compute Cloud available.
So these are the
kind of technologies
where I'm trying to offload
at least part of the generator
aspect into the cloud.
If you have, for instance,
just your mobile phone,
you can't expect to generate
a mesh with half a million
vertices and kill your battery
not in the next 10 minutes.
PAUL KINLAN: So I
have a question.
Why would you need half
a million vertices?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Because what I'm
after is really to explore how
a very simple design process can
create a super
complex shape or form.
And I don't want to
necessarily restrict
what those forms can be.
Obviously the design
process and options
were restricted
indirectly, but I
don't know yet what
the restrictions are.
And I think it's a very that's
where it goes more into the art
world, in my opinion, is that
what we are building here,
or what I am proposing
to build here
is actually an open
ended world, potentially.
And it will be
down to the people
and the interested parties who
will take part in that journey
to explore what
that is, actually.
And I think this is where
you have a big difference
to a commercial client
project, where the client has
a specific aim, what
needs to be achieved
and here, this is
more or less fluid.
PAUL KINLAN: So
one of the things
that we were talking about,
this constrained language.
So it's the client that is
constrained by the-- can you
talk about how the
client and the server--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: So
I need to explain
a bit more what the
design process is.
So right now, the whole
project is called Code Factory,
but this is really
just a working title.
And it still is a
form of factory,
what we are talking
about, but I think
there needs to be more reference
to my recent thinking, which
is all to do with biology
and initial embryonic stages
of development.
So once you have
the egg splitting
into the initial ball of cells
and then actually forming
a fully 3D object from an
initial almost flat structure.
And so the design options
I'm exploring right now
are simply doing proposing
a process which only allows
you to subdivide existing
structures to extrude them
or to actually replicate
them in different directions.
And from those
three options, there
are a few other
candidates which I still
need to explore technically,
if this is actually possible.
From those three
options, you should
be able to generate a large
number of possibilities.
And again, I don't want
to limit what you can do.
But we can look at
some examples later.
PAUL KINLAN: We're going
to switch to the screen.
Switch now, or?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: So
what you see here
is basically left
hand side are my EMacs
and the right hand
side shows MeshLab,
which is an open
source mesh viewer.
So what you see here on the left
basically in Clojure and that--
PAUL KINLAN: Clojure with a J?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Clojure with a J, yes.
And we will get to that.
There's also closure with an s.
And that is Google's offering.
Obviously a lot of you
probably will know that.
So what this is here using is
it has not technically so much
to do with DevArt
just yet, but it's
using all the meshing
tools I've been building
for the last few months to
actually make all that happen.
But we can also start
with something simple.
So for instance, we
have here an axis
aligned bounding box, an AABB.
You can look that
up on Wikipedia.
So that's basically just a
cube positioned in 3D space.
And we turn this into a mesh and
then we can also smoothen this,
but let's just not do
it in the beginning.
So if I refresh here.
PAUL KINLAN: So you told
me earlier about the,
was it the Catmull-Clark?
Was there--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yeah,
so, Catmull-Clark
is the name of a mesh
subdivision algorithm invented
by Ed Catmull, and I
forgot this first name
of the other person, Clark.
Sorry.
But Ed Catmull is one of the
founders of Pixar and formerly
Industrial Light & Magic.
And what you can
basically do with that,
so we have here the simple cube.
And that is obviously
very boring.
But then we can for instance
start running this also
through the subdivision process.
And now it already
looks like this.
And because this can
be applied recursively.
So if I reevaluate this,
refresh this after two stages,
and if you do here
say for instance five,
then it is a really smooth mesh.
Even though technically
you are still only working
with a box which is
eight points in space,
you fuse simple
transformations, you end up
with something far more complex.
Here's another example where
we, for instance, start
with a circle radius
100 and we turn it
into a hexagon in this line.
And then we extrude that
hexagon along the set axis
and we end up with basically
something like that.
Boring, but that's
besides the point.
And then here we can
also extrude, instead
of just the solid--
let's go a bit higher up,
we extrude actually as a shell.
So we basically get now
some walls on the side.
And we also run this through
another subdivision process
called Doo-Sabin,
which is almost
the same as Catmull-Clark.
And now I was too fast.
We have to edit that.
Come on.
Yeah, here it was.
And, oops.
It needs to be edited, sorry.
PAUL KINLAN: That's cool.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Refresh.
So here, then we end up
with something like that.
So that was still
technically you
can see the pentagon
very vaguely.
One, two, three, four, five.
But it has been smoothed
and we don't actually
use all the points
for the side wall,
so you can very quickly
get complex stuff here.
We can also remove the
bottom and the top.
So that means we will only
get the side walls now.
And I was too fast again.
Sorry.
So now we only end up
with the side walls.
But it's actually not connected,
so if we want the full shape,
then we can-- there we go.
You can still vaguely
see the pentagon.
So here, you basically have
those three parameters again.
The radius, number
of teeth, and then we
define a profile,
which is basically
the shape of an
individual tooth.
And we can evaluate
that as well.
And that forms then
something like this.
So if you see, it's like
two lines of code really.
And it's a super
powerful way of thinking
about how objects are
actually designed.
Everything is
parametric, everything
can be replaced
by another process
so that 100 might be coming in
from some other previous stage.
And there's no reason why this
couldn't be, for instance,
combined with a physics engine
which then actually calculates
the rotation of the cogs if
you would have more than one
in a system.
And the other nice
thing is those files
are immediately 3D printable.
There's no further
post processing needed.
So the reason now
maybe I should talk
about why I am using
closure for that.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
that'd be cool.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Which is, so Clojure
is a modern dialect of Lisp.
And right now, as I'm
evaluating this here,
this is running on the JVM.
So basically all that
code you see on the left
is compiled into Java bytecode.
And Clojure has since 2012, if
I'm not mistaken-- yes summer
of 2012-- it has a dialect
which is called clojurescript.
And that uses the Google
closure with an s compiler
to actually compile into really
heavily optimized JavaScript.
So that means all that code
I am having here, I actually
can compile into JavaScript
and run as well in the browser.
PAUL KINLAN: That's cool.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: And there's
actually so much development
happening around clojurescript
in the entire toolchain.
So it's a super new project
and a super new language.
Two years is nothing.
But there's a lot of
momentum happening.
And we have, for instance,
a so-called browser rebel,
where you can have a
browser window open, enter
your normal text editor.
And all the changes
you do immediately
get pushed into
the browser and you
can create your DOM from
your normal text editor
and manipulate anything.
So that's even almost better
than JavaScript itself,
even though it's using all
of the technology already
existing.
Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: So
you see yourself--
I see we're probably
not going to have
a cog function at DevArt.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
Of course, no, no.
As I say, those functions here,
they are for me to explore,
not to explore, more
test the meshing
features because all the meshes
itself is basically a graph
structure and I need
to have something
which can be
verified technically
if all the subdivisions
actually makes sense,
or the extrusion processes.
So having a workflow like this
where I have a 3D preview tied
to my editor is a perfect
way of developing.
PAUL KINLAN: So what's the
next step for you in this?
Because at some point, you're
going to have to go to-- this
is what I'm actually
trying to explore myself,
is that at some point you're
going to have to go not
to product but to
get the point where--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Prototype.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah,
the prototype.
And then the final
implementation.
Is this what you're doing here?
Is this going to drive that?
Or is this going to be
kind of complete scratched?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
No, the toolchain
is what I'm really working on.
I have been working on
for over a year by now.
It's actually the
fourth iteration.
So basically, I maybe have
to rewind a little bit.
So that project I
mentioned earlier,
which I started in 2007,
was called toxiclibs.
And that was basically a
library for Java initially.
And it became one of
the biggest library
packages for Processing,
and mainly has
been used with Processing, even
though personally I have mainly
used it with just Java.
But in terms of
getting an audience,
all the people I
wanted to address they
are from the Processing camp.
So it made sense to make
it friendly with Processing
itself.
And right now, this is
the fourth iteration
off a redevelopment of
toxiclibs but in Clojure.
Since I really want to go
back to web development more.
And actually the browsers,
especially Chrome,
have moved on so much
in the last few years
where you can do those
things now realistically
in the browser, not just
on 5% of the audience.
But it's now mainstream and
you can do all those things.
And what I also think there's
still a niche, because there's
a lot of rendering engines and
3D engines for games and shader
development and eye candy
stuff for web browsers.
But this is more or less,
again, from the modeling side.
I'm really highly interested in
the digital fabrication side.
So for me, the geometry
aspects are far more important
than the actual representation.
PAUL KINLAN: That's cool.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: And you
can always piggy back,
combine that with three.js or
any of the other frameworks
you have.
So it doesn't need
to be reinvented.
PAUL KINLAN: OK.
So what do you see
your next step as?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: So my
next step is to really--
and I actually made that
step already, I just
have nothing visually
to show yet--
is to really work
on the operators
which you can use to
create structures.
So this is almost
thick, and that
will be checked in over the
weekend into the GitHub.
PAUL KINLAN: I think by the
time that this goes out,
it'll probably already
be checked in there.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: OK, then it
will be already checked in.
PAUL KINLAN: It's already done.
Check it out.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yeah, exactly.
And the next stage,
then, is to start
developing in UI for that.
Because right now
it is a nightmare
to actually explore a
lot of those options
because it is super abstract to
edit how those processes relate
to each other.
So I think the UI
development is what
I will focus on for
the next two weeks.
And then the stage after that is
actually to focus on App Engine
and integrate this all
with the different modules.
PAUL KINLAN: This
is going to sound
like another really
stupid question.
How do you decide when to stop?
Like when you're done
with these things?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: When
I run out of time.
PAUL KINLAN: Is
that literally it?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Literally, yes.
What I said earlier.
I think deadlines are important
to stop procrastination,
but for me personally,
they're also
a hard stop for refactoring.
I'm a manic refactorer.
And as I said, this is
the fourth iteration
of the library.
I have three previous almost
completely developed prototypes
I've throw out after doing
one or two projects with them
because I realize that's
not what I wanted.
And I also am quite
hardcore where
I'm not shy to just pull
the plug on something
if I don't think that IS
an innovation, personally.
PAUL KINLAN: So this happens
in a lot of communities.
And this is going
to sound stupid.
Everything I say, I think
is going to sound stupid.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: It doesn't.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank you.
We'll have you on as another
guest again for that.
No, what I was going to
say was this whole kind
of pulling the plug on
things that don't work
or things that don't work
for you at least anyway.
You yourself, I think you're
probably happy with that.
But what happens
to the people who
potentially use your products?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Well,
that's another thing why
I'm especially with this case,
it's not really second album
syndrome, but it's a little bit.
There are like over 70,000
downloads for toxiclibs.
So it's quite a
substantial number.
And I know it is being
used by a lot of people
on a regular basis.
And I realize that,
how you say, it
is very hard to do something
which fits my, sorry, rewind.
So the initial reason
for developing toxiclibs
was to actually
propel my own work.
And it had to fit my own
workflow and my own skill
set and I only then once
I realized, OK there's
interest by the
community, I started
then pushing and developing
lots of examples.
And I did over 20 workshops
at universities worldwide.
And a lot of those
workshops really
have been a huge help factor
for actually developing
more examples, which
have newcomers.
And what I realized, though,
is that a lot of people
still like the more
mathematical knowledge.
Not everything in this field
is related to actual coding.
And a lot of the
things you can't
solve by just copy pasting.
And most newcomers
really just copy paste.
I've been there.
I mean, you know the argument.
If early web browsers wouldn't
have had reuse source,
HTML would have never taken off.
And the whole web itself,
not to this extent.
So I think this is super
important, copy pasting,
but at the same time you realize
that some of the assumptions
I made, and especially
being a Java based library,
you always try to fit
into the language.
And now I even wrote a huge
blog post in 2011 or '12,
I can't remember now, how I
see toxiclibs progressing.
And Clojure was part
of that equation.
But I still hope
to have something
which is compatible with
the previous version.
But those languages are almost
orthagonal to each other
in terms of approach and
in terms of flexibility
and what you can do.
So why would I want
to limit myself now
to do something which worked
with the previous version?
Then I end up with an
MS-DOS kind of thing.
PAUL KINLAN: I was
going to say, it
feels like the
Microsoft problem.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: It's
legacy problem in general.
So I think this is a
small enough project where
you can have a clean slate.
And even if you believe
in semantic versioning
like a lot of developers
do these days,
every time you have a
major version change,
that is basically
a breaking change,
or a total re-imagining, of
what has been there before.
Now, I think that's
where I am at this stage.
And that's why I've been
also taking my time not
to get it right, you can ever
get it right for everyone.
But I think I've done
now a lot of projects,
three commercial
ones, few examples.
Where I see OK that works, and
it's actually understandable.
I think even you without
knowing closure much.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
What I really love
is this kind of-- maybe you
can switch back to the screen--
but like in Clojure, you have
those kind of arrow operators
which are kind of threading
and building pipelines
almost like in Unix
where you have the pipe.
So the output of
one process becomes
the input for the next one.
And that's a very nice way of--
PAUL KINLAN: So me
just trying to think
about your final product.
So the idea was that
you could potentially,
the final piece of art
essentially, this sculpture
that is printed at the
end is just basically
a series of pipes of all those
different multiple operations.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Exactly.
PAUL KINLAN: Boom
boom, boom boom.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
And then we talked
earlier about this,
about that there's
a whole relationship to biology.
So it's not just the
cell division aspect.
It's also thinking about it from
a kind of genetic programming
perspective.
So you have on the one side, you
have the visitors in the museum
being the curators and kind
of the fitness function
of this genetic process, or the
genetic programming process.
And then you have the authors
or designers, artists,
who use the design
who are actually
the population of
every generation.
And there will be this
competition between those two
camps to decide
what will be printed
and what is actually
popular with the public.
And that is on a macro level.
On a technical level, all
those operates actually
form a tree structure.
So you can actually then copy
and paste different branches
from those trees.
And recycle basically DNA
sequences or subsections
of DNA for that object.
And you can just say, OK,
I have already here a half
finished object, but
I want to now take
that piece of DNA and copy
and paste it to this fragment
and see what happens.
PAUL KINLAN: That's cool.
So we're probably going
to start to wrap up.
There's a lot more I actually
want to talk to you about.
So we would probably I'm going
to get commitment from you.
Will you be able to do another
one of these [INAUDIBLE]?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yeah.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
There we are.
You heard it.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Not
next week, though.
PAUL KINLAN: Not next week.
No we'll toggle that.
We'll wait a couple of weeks.
It'll be fine.
But I suppose one of the
things I want to try and get
from this as well
is there's going
to be a whole bunch of people
who are looking at DevArt who
are just like me, who
can code pretty well.
We're all very
technical, and we want
to have a bit of an
outlet to try and explore
what we can do
creatively with our code.
If you could give
one piece of advice
for getting people to
start thinking about this
or even implementing
stuff, what would it be?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Several
pieces of advice.
Don't be afraid of
making mistakes is one.
Like some of the most
interesting things
I ever developed
is by having a bug.
Which then turned out to
be a blessing in disguise.
And also you can't
approach those projects
very much with a fixed
mindset that you say, OK,
literally examine-- I
want to create here a cog.
That is fine.
That's a small step.
I can approach it like a
normal well defined process.
But if you just want to
think about the power
of, say, generative
design more, you
need to more think
about, OK, what
are my ingredients
without actually knowing
what will come out as a result.
And then be surprised.
And then it's
simply refactoring.
And you check different
variations of parameters
and you let it play.
And it's this really
interactive iterative process.
But it's more
iterative in the sense
that the process, because you
don't know what you will end up
with actually is guiding
your own thinking as well.
And I really think
that you don't
have that in other
parts of design so much.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
That's cool.
Say developers don't
really know where to start.
Would it be Processing,
for instance, [INAUDIBLE]?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: I still think
Processing is the best gateway
drug to that world, yes.
PAUL KINLAN: So
Processing, [INAUDIBLE].
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
OpenFrameworks as well.
I mean, again, it
depends what you do.
If you want to do more
interactive things which
require a lot of, say, real
time video input computer vision
type stuff, or you have intense
number pushing going on,
I would use openFrameworks.
But then again,
you're on the language
which is C, very low level.
You have a lot of package
simply from that language level
where a framework can only
help you that much with.
If you are simply after
quick exploration for idea
of ideas without having to
learn really hard language,
Processing is better
or even JavaScript.
There's so many.
I mean Processing by now I
really don't see as a tool
itself anymore.
It is an approach which
has taken over and heavily
influenced almost every
other tool developed
since then in that field.
So I think there are so
many JavaScript libraries.
I don't know about.
PAUL KINLAN: I'll do that.
I'll put a collection of
a couple of them together
and you'll be able to click on
them from this video at least.
I think there's some on
the DevArt site as well.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Yeah, I'm sure.
PAUL KINLAN: So
yeah, that's cool.
So yes, thank you very much.
We're going to have to
do another one of these
as well, because there's a
lot of-- we talked about 3D
printing a little bit
earlier on before the show.
And it's really interesting and
I'd like to go into the whole--
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Bring
it in the next time.
PAUL KINLAN: Are you serious?
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
I don't know yet.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, cool.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT:
We could, we could.
PAUL KINLAN: We'll see.
We'll see what happens.
But anyway, thank you
very much for watching.
If you're interested
in exploring what's
possible with DevArt, go
to devart.withgoogle.com.
Or you can click on the link
just below when it appears.
That was pretty cool, wasn't it?
You can click on the link
or just follow Karsten
as well on Twitter and
other social networks
that you might be on as well.
Cool.
Thank you.
KARSTEN SCHMIDT: Thank you.
Bye.